you know the 1 through 10 scale
everybody knows about this okay
would you say that guys know their score
um i think that guy men generally
undervalue themselves and women
overvalue themselves okay and the reason
for that is because there's no such
thing as a plus size male model right um
and there shouldn't be i'm not look i'm
not trying to buy draws if i see a dude
my size wearing those drums do you
understand what i'm saying but but by
the same token women are taught to feel
good about themselves no matter what
like janito fantastic figure we have
women who are literally four times
janeta's size like i don't know maybe
lizzo and every time she takes a bikini
picture lizzo smolders the internet with
a red hot well of course if lizzo gets
that kind of pub then of course the
average rank and file girl who's
probably a five thinks she's a seven
yeah i don't i don't know any guy
realistically who's not making that much
money out of shape you know not doesn't
have that much game if i said what's
your score i'm a 10 bro i'm a good bro
he gets he's like look dude you know
maybe on a best day i'm a seven but i
really need to improve guys kind of have
a little more awareness
you know i watch russian fit i'm sure
you guys do my guys uh myron and fresh
and they have girls go around the table
and they're all tense
somehow they're all tense i'm a 15.
right it's okay like yeah so would you
do you think that women
are sort of an inflated sense of self
because of the yes uh
feminine indoctrination and the boss
babe thing and go get it girl like do
women know all right
probably is i'm probably a funny seven
but i'm going to call myself a 10.
how we rating these women because
who who made this scale and what is it
based on so you got to give me some
context okay so what is lizzo what is
she i'm asking you what's lizzo's score
lizzo is a 10. on or
like give me context or based on what
just
looking at liz oh just look yes that's
exactly what we're talking about
okay
so what's her score
what's lizzo's score she said that she's
a df decent face
um
i need a number
and you can use decimals well since
she's pretty in the face yeah and thick
in the waist
that's a little more than thick i need a
number not a conversation
[ __ ] [ __ ] the 4.5 4.5
okay on the richter scale on the richter
um what would you say that lizzo is
in terms of attractiveness yeah she's a
one she's a one oh i have a lot too far
well i mean listen say what you want but
but you ask the
all the men around the world mm-hmm very
few of them would actually have
relations with lizzo if they had better
options yeah that's how you wrote
something
around let me get a score from seven and
then i'm gonna get to my point here go
ahead what's lizzo oh
a two she's a two yeah okay pull up a
picture of lizzo because we're just
talking about lizzo right now okay
by the way um
we're kind of going off the deep end on
lizzo but this is an example
of like you struggled to even give lizzo
a score and i get it you don't want to
you know get cancelled and ruffle some
feathers you know you probably bought
lizzo's latest album i get it yeah i
like music and i'm good with that okay
but we have to really
yeah
okay so let's lizzo boom images let's go
oh my god all right lizzy okay go to the
one in the green oh okay that that one
okay that is a very big girl
and yes i do think that she is pretty in
the face so she'll give her a couple
points for that but you can't tell me
that the body's attractive you just
can't her face would be crazy like that
okay somebody likes that there are
chubby chasers around the world you're
right
yes but
she is
awesome i don't no doubt but she's a
wonderful okay how about this i'm sure
she is how about this
in terms of money muscles game right for
for men money
she's 10 10 right um
game she's got some swag
ten
but when it comes to quote unquote
muscles or looks we'll just substitute
looks she's not a ten guy well we're
imagining
well we're measuring her on masculine
on masculine metrics men who have
options we're not worried about a
woman's money okay we're worried is she
submissive is she obedient um is she is
she docile is she a team player is she
attractive lizzo's she's made more she
made more money this week than i'll make
in my entire life that does not one bit
of good for her on the central
marketplace and lizzo knows it as a
matter of fact i think
and it's funny lizzo hides her pain in
plain sight she wants everybody to think
that we think but she wants p she wants
everyone to think that we think that she
thinks she's attractive so is a
psychologist now
well it doesn't take a psychologist to
see that lizzo is your opinion and by
the way i like her music i mean kelly
real quick pull up sports illustrated
cover oh boy
and then next to that bert
kreischer
e-i-s-h-e-r
okay and hit images this guy is awesome
all right here's the male version of
lizzo um
okay scroll down
because i think that he's actually gonna
come on let's go to that forbes article
vote
america's billionaire comedian that's
not that's not real he's a 240 yeah okay
okay you can't see his gut there
go to that he does all of his shoes okay
as a man i could tell you bert ain't
that hot hilarious he's got money but he
don't exactly have the muscles and the
looks we can say that as men and we're
not gonna get upset ladies what number
is bert you don't know what he's talking
you don't know how much money he's got
in his bank account you don't know his
jokes you don't know if he's famous or
not famous this is a loaded question
what she likes funny guys okay what's
his number though physically
physically yes can i can i
can i subtract from it
but what's give us a number
give us a number um
negative two so he's not attractive oh
my god devin that three he's a three
kelly
i'm not rating anybody you're not going
to give anyone a score i'm not ready
okay someone she called lizzie okay
here's what i'll tell you i did not she
did not get no
here we go and i respect that you don't
want to give a score but i need an
answer this next question okay why won't
you give a score because i i really
believe in getting to know a person a
person is infinitely can become
infinitely more attractive or less
attractive based on my interaction with
them that is true
it's
there is a emotional thing an
intelligent connection it doesn't even
matter money gain whatever that stuff is
my interaction with you
i like you a million times better
haven't gotten to know you right no
that's extremely true and by the way
well what she's saying is is absolutely
right
and it usually is more the case for
women because they might see a guy
and they're like you know
and then they they get to know him and
he's kind of funny and you know
endearing and charming and who they
thought was a five he's actually an
eight that's right guys we get it no
one's an exact score i'll give you an
example
again i live in south beach i'm in the
nightlife i see models galore
i might see someone who's oh sh that
girl is a tent
and then i speak with her and i'm like
she is
the worst human ever yes that's she's
weird
she's still a 10 physically but she's a
horrible 10. right there's a difference
yes amen we have the ability to
compartmentalize our sexual attention
from our regular attention correct i've
had sex with so many girls i literally
cannot stand that's just how we are no
and it's funny here we actually like ew
it's not impossible but women don't want
to have sex with guys they don't like if
guy dude a guy could look like shamar
more and idris elba's love child if he
if he acts like jaleel white or steve
urkel you guys aren't interested in yeah
he can get it
you
i'll tell you this well that's good
because i'll tell you this there's no
amount of conversational skill or human
development that's going to make lizzo
attractive to me she could be the
world's she could be the world's most
altruistic human she can have you know
she could give to i mean i'm sure she
does
does philanthropic things around the
world that's what and i will applaud her
for that i'm not trying to stick my dick
in her
and i don't think anybody is yeah so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauscast click right here
[Music]